okay
goodbye
[Music]
i know
you find it hard when you're
i know
you feel alone
inside your hope is no longer
a place
[Music]
and i know you try your best
[Music]
just like
[Music]
i know
that you are scared we weren't prepared
[Music]
a
[Music]
motivation fading
[Music]
just know
we feel
it too
sometimes we just
your
quiet now
so quiet now
[Music]
just know
i feel
it
just like
with you
you want food
hello everyone
that kid saying plum is like the best
part of that song how are you all doing
hey jeff i have no idea who that kid was
just
some kid in the park
hopefully i can't get sued for that
plum glam yeah
it was such a cute little conversation
that i managed to just get on recording
and i was like i need to put that in the
song
hey sidnator
hey deaf hello everyone watching
today is the last stream of 2021 what
the hell where is the year gone
it's actually
gone so freaking fast hasn't it
is it just me
can't be just me
surely you think it's gone fast as well
that kid is famous man no
not really but i mean
maybe he'll hear the song one day and
he'll be like that sounds like me as a
kid although no one ever says that ever
because all kids kind of sound the same
i won't be able to know what i sounded
like when i was a kid
hey clay
hey mark druid professor plum of course
of course professor plum
yeah last stream of 2021
so i'm going to sing you a little song
now uh it's a song called peter that i
came across by a daughter and
it was like lily as well it was like a
little collaboration that they did and
it was such a cute little song so i
thought it sing a few
and then we will finish alan wake
i'm i actually have no idea how it's
gonna end it's it's gonna be i'm
guessing we're gonna prevail
you know good old allen is gonna win
over the darkness even though he's just
a writer and he can't even run very well
but
we will prevail i'm sure
anyway
i'll start with a little song
oh yeah i don't remember the start of
the year
i do i guess it's only because like at
the start of the year i moved into this
place and it doesn't feel like i've been
here for that long so i'm like what the
hell it's nearly been a year [ __ ]
i can't believe it
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
peter
can i
go back home i flew here under false
pretense i thought it would be fun
but the lost boys have all moved away
and one of them's locked up
i know you think he's still a child but
i couldn't give a [ __ ] you're 21
[Music]
no
peter
i can't dream no more
i've been chasing all of yours that i've
forgotten what it was that i wanted
[Music]
[Music]
so please don't you ask me too
you say that i don't look so
good in yellow
like how the dolls they do
[Music]
like other talks they do
[Music]
oh peter
i am not naive i see the way you look at
her you don't do that for me it must be
love
and we both know it's not with us
[Music]
[Music]
no i won't be your tall
so please don't you ask me too
you say that i don't look so good in
yellow
like color don'ts they do
[Music]
like other tones they do
[Music]
oh
peter
he walks beside the lake while i lay
beside an
empty space waiting for
[Music]
the sirens
just waiting for
[Music]
the sirens
no i won't be your
doll
so please don't you ask me
too i
won't shut my little
[Music]
too
[Music]
there you go
that's a little song called peter well
it's a it's a it's a cover of a song
called peter by daughter and i i think
it's
lolly
or something
it's pretty nice i hadn't heard it
before it's such a nice song
hello nelson hello cat louise well loads
of people just like joined in
hello weird eurasian boy
what an interesting name
um
hello uh did i say nelson yeah i did i
made it to this live show earlier ago
happy thursday happy thursday hey
dorothy scott
love your beautiful talented voice oh
that's so cute thank you
okay
now let's get on with the gaming
the gaming section of the
live stream how are you doing today
all right tired i'm sure we can all
agree it's definitely time for christmas
break i'm so tired in work just doing
the tiniest things is so like draining
at the moment but
tomorrow is my last day at work so very
excited and then i get to travel
quite far to go and see my family but
i'm excited for it should be it should
be good
how are you
final spin of alan wake
peter rabbit
what
uh
your voice makes me calm and happy ah
i'm glad thank you cat louise i hope i'm
not butchering your name
i'm glad it makes you happy it's very
nice let's get up the game
i mean you say calm you're not going to
be calm in a second because of what
we're playing
but at least it started off calm so
yeah
as usual let me know if i'm too loud the
game's too loud whatever should be fine
though it should be okay
i'm gonna get a job next year expect
some donors if all goes well oh thank
you but
more
to you getting a job so hope all goes
well i hope you enjoy the job as well
because that's very important too
or at least find some satisfaction
because you can't always enjoy a job of
course
but
you're hoping to get somewhere that you
know you can get a little bit of
satisfaction from the job that's all you
want really
we need someone to follow
to check volume
oh right of the uh notifications yeah
they're very loud they're very loud
i should probably turn it down shouldn't
i
okay last episode let's do this let's
find out how this crazy ass game ends
also this alleyway 2 did everyone see it
did everyone see the trailer for alan
wake too at the game awards very
exciting of course we're going to be
playing that on the channel but you know
it's going to be a long way away yet but
we're previously on alan wake i wrote a
horror story that has come true thomas
zane did the same in the 70s you will go
no further if i continue like the dark
presence wants me to the story i'm
writing won't save alice it's a horror
story no one will survive you know zayn
thomas zane you're the lady of the light
in the song he left something behind to
help me the clicker ellen thought of
this as he stood on the rim of cauldron
lake the clicker in his hand he took a
deep breath
and jumped
i can get to her now i can finish this
i'm just thinking of allen holding a
clicker from last of us
[Music]
[Music]
i had a hangover
my head was about to explode and the
light hurt my eyes
i needed my sunglasses and painkillers
to deal the pain
in one of my finer moments of
self-deception i swore to quit drinking
oh right
he's back in this oh back in his
apartment i was like they didn't go
drinking again because they didn't go
drinking to get him in barry jesus this
is quite some hangover
his head is swamping
oh glasses they always help a hangover
don't they
and like dull the light the sunglasses
made the world look bearable
now i could keep my eyes open without
feeling like a vampire in the sun
vampire
oh maybe he is a vampire
that's why him and his
his girlfriend would never work out
what's that icky noise
please tell me it's
supposed to be in the game because i'm
starting to wonder
started to seem bearable again
whoa look at this massive wet room
that's what that's called via like a wet
room that's a fancy ass shower dude
there was a message waiting for me on
the machine
you have one new message ow
are you still asleep
wakey wakey
you should have your show on your table
if alice wasn't too mad to record it as
she called me earlier and really chewed
me out yeah yeah we went a little
overboard last night but parties are a
part of this business
ow look i'm saying this is your friend
she's not doing your career any favors
by trying to run your life like that
okay
i'll talk to you later i'll watch the
show well i mean if if he does have a
drinking problem then she's just looking
out for his well-being oh
i'm just walking on my furniture cool
sound
i'd been a guest on the talk show the
previous night talking about my latest
book
the show was supposed to be waiting for
me on artivo
tivo can they are they not allowed to
say tv
what is a tivo
hmm
i've been talking with the best-selling
author alan wake about his new book the
sudden stop
yeah good read go buy it oh that's it no
it is a good read look uh i'm gonna be
honest here is that wise
i'm gonna do it anyway i got people who
give me the lowdown on books i'm a busy
guy
but this one i actually read from cover
to cover i mean i'm i'm a big fan
wow thanks wow this might be a spoiler
for those who haven't read the book yet
based on the sales figures the two
people out there who haven't read the
book yet
but this last book is all about the
death of the main character the
hard-boiled new york detective alex
casey now there's been a lot of outrage
about this
why the hell did you kill casey what the
hell were you thinking man good riddance
no seriously though
seven years in six books is a long time
he was a gloomy guy to spend all your
working hours with and it was a good run
but it's time to explore new things my
next book will be a departure from the
old people didn't like him changing it
up we already knew this though didn't we
you've certainly given us a lot of
entertainment over the years
oh she's back she was a gloomy guy
did you watch the show i didn't say
anything stupid if that's what you're
wearing
okay grumpy
you want an aspen or something are you
going to start with me about drinking
now you know what
go back to sleep allen nothing
yeah he is being a douche
what now you can't even talk to me well
this morning i was angry because you
said you'd be home at midnight and you
showed up at 7am and passed out in
mid-sentence
now i'm over it are you angry this
goddamn tour it's gotten out of hand
oh honey
it's almost over right
we can get back to normal then you can
start writing again
i'm sorry honey
alan
you're not thinking straight just take a
shower and go back to bed huh
yeah you're right honey
i'm sorry once this is over let's go
away together a vacation just you and me
some peace and quiet
so that's right after the first book but
then he didn't write for years wasn't it
like two years or something so
that was quite a long time ago
somehow the clicker was the key to the
cabin i had to return to cauldron lake
to save alice
i'm going back to the lake to finish
this i'm going to write an ending to the
story in the manuscript on my own terms
to make it all right why can't you just
write it here the last page is still in
the typewriter i need to read it first
everything needs to be just right zane
tried to cut some corners and it didn't
end well
okay ready when you are
i'm sorry sarah but i need to do this
alone barry take her gun you don't need
to freaking point a gun out
i need to do this alone
it's like all right she probably would
have been fine with it anyway
oh barry
[Music]
it was warm and sunny i'd flick the
switch of the clicker had it done this
i didn't stop to question it i had to
take advantage of the sunlight to get to
the lake
on zane's page i'd stood on the room of
cauldron lake about to use the clicker
that's where it was headed
[Music]
yeah today will be the final episode of
night springs exciting
all right how many times will we die
this episode in daylight surrounded by
the beauty of the pacific northwest
landscape
it was hard not to let doubt creep in
one last yeah
i could still chalk everything up to a
dream a delusion i had enough
imagination to make up something like
this having been in the cabin all this
time trapped in a story inside my head
gone mad from grief over alice's death
like hartman had claimed there would be
no way of knowing
i told myself it didn't really matter
nope my course was set
yes
so i could get in the car what's down
this way probably nothing you're
probably wasting time let's just go
is there anything down here though i'm
just gonna check
it's very dark in here i don't like it
no absolutely [ __ ] all
okay
well at least oh god
i can't drive
okay look at the road i was trying to
like look over here at the nice view but
i can't do that i've got to look at the
road
it's like real life
eyes on the road
anything here
uh how do i get out again
i might take the other car
ooh batteries
yes please
yeah i'm gonna save this car
because why not
[Music]
maybe we're gonna get out
digger digger
drift queen
sure let's say that's that's what i was
doing yes i knew it
see
most of the time if you do take the time
to look around this game does reward you
quite nicely are we supposed to be going
down here i think we are
uh should i be driving then um perhaps
but
let's just walk down
it's that little stash box
where's my volume
up
there
hell yeah
okay we are prepared
we are so bad
well glad we had a little look
surely his cardio is improved right now
i mean you would hope so
here here is your proof
that it has not no
mark's like you would think that
no
no no no no no
no no no
[Music]
okay we got some goodies let's get back
on the road
[Music]
stop and smell the hunting miracles
it is a nice smell
should we go check that house out i feel
like we should check the house out let's
go take the house out
nothing gets missed when you play with
the jagman x okay
well
almost nothing unless it's like a really
difficult and then i just gotta go
because i just kind of go
you can't get in
excuse me did you hear that noise
that's weird
okey-dokey then
coffee addiction
i mean he's a writer
oh shite
oh balls
fine
i guess i gotta
jump over
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the darkness that
touched me
there was a link between us always would
be i could feel its presence again
getting closer oh
so nothing actually happened okay
i just jumped into the car
i'm surprised not vomited coffee out due
to exhaustion what a scene
so can i not like
come on dude yeah okay
bye
can i get in this car that doesn't look
too beat up fine
quick do the clicker
ah
reload
and we got a page
we've still got a strong flashlight oh
game it really likes us
this sun is just out strong thank you
the dark presence was no longer trying
to capture the writer so he could create
the ending it wanted the writer knew too
much he was too strong and he carried a
weapon left behind by thomas zane
something that could hurt it
now the darkness was doing everything in
its power to simply stop the rider from
ever reaching cauldron lake and the dark
place it came yeah this is gonna be fun
he's gonna throw everything it has at us
hey i really love you
welcome oh shy though
oh yeah
cars are always extremely helpful in
these scenarios
we got another car there and another car
there and another car there another girl
room from fran
i just [ __ ] spawned it i know where
me
ah scheiser
ah whatever you know what [ __ ] you
you can't catch me because i'm in a car
and you're not fast enough
i'm gonna end up dying because i'm not i
didn't take the time to kill those
suckers what about up here
so any lights up here
there's cars
anyone here
okay i think we're good i think we get
okay scout the car car is smoking
get out of the car
a car is smoking
thank you thank you thank you
the majestic motel refundable 100
security deposit is required on all
reservations no personal checks accepted
we take our major credit cards and bank
cards check out time it's 10 am no loud
music no pits
what a boring place one vehicle but i
don't
if you're a senior or a better ask about
discounts okay
oh coffee coffee in the toilet okay
i mean it does help you poop
based on the signature in the motel
register agent nightingale had stayed
here in room number two
number two oh that's probably not even
lollies
oh do you want a shoddy
you know shoddy
how much ammo for the shotty
six
you're right now
i think we just need more bullets i i
know i love shotguns
but we just do need more bullets room
number six room number six six six
tres quattro [ __ ]
where was that noise from
what was i counting
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know
let's just try all of those
it's gonna be more
somewhere
oh [ __ ]
this had obviously been the room where
agent nightingale had stayed when he
hadn't been busy harassing me
why
he's got pictures of everybody why is he
got pictures of everybody
creepy dude he's got a picture of barry
on his nightstand
can you blame him
ah [ __ ] jesus what the hell was that
what happened
i don't even know come on
[ __ ] off little [ __ ] bag
oh
i can't do it through
i guess like these little poles were
stopping it
okay i don't really understand what i
was looking for though did i find it
i think i was just exploring
i do like to do that
should we jump over here with our car i
mean it looks like we can but it also
looks very dangerous
let's do it
is there another car we could use
like one that's not as beat up as my
smoking one
i think we have to go with the smoking
one okay
nope one way
we've won time
[Music]
uh
it might be a better card here
is there anything up here for something
to
read
no not
no coffee to drink
i guess i could drive that van
can i drive the
van oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
quick stop being so slow
you can't even drive the van
get in
drive your spooky car
don't hit anything
he probably needs a drive
a van license
[ __ ]
of the things are happening
[ __ ]
turn around
yeah [ __ ] take this
oh my god i can hardly see
drip queen living up to her name
oh my gosh
[Music]
here it comes
i'm the monster now where are you
where are they
where did they go
what
am i still fighting someone
wait
there you are you little [ __ ]
i see ya
whoa there's so many of you now where'd
you come from
i've refused to leave the car until i
have to by the way because
it's probably not as fun for you to
watch
but it's fun for me
girls die
drift queen
where are you
[ __ ] there you are
yes
feel the wrath
of my smokey smoky car
thank you so much inferno for the super
chat i really appreciate that
the bing will probably come in like five
minutes it's always very late
i'm glad you like the streams
um
i went the wrong bloody way shaiza let
me just go through the bars you're not
that large
fine
come on little allen
you can do this this is the way i'm
supposed to go yeah oh look there's a
little light here
he's a geyser
here comes the surprise
what was the surprise was it me and my
drifting skills
[ __ ]
where
i don't like that ominous thing with
like horns in the background ah
[ __ ] it hit me in the head
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god jesus christ
hello
hello
hello
oh you're where did it go
oh
can i pick anything up [ __ ]
i don't know let's just [ __ ] run
what the hell
ah
okay
plot twist allen is actually obese and
that's how he can't run somehow he
invented a thin man suit that works oh
because he's like
he's still wondering whether it's in his
head this is in his head and he's just
rewritten himself as something man
[Music]
it's a good idea i see i see your point
they go
oh yeah i could be using these flares
they would help
nah
[Music]
don't scare me
what the hell
oh [ __ ]
i was going to take my time with it
because i need to let my flashlight
um recharge anyway i could just change
the batteries but you know i want to
save the battery
that was close
okay so i went this way last time then
it went above ground and
and then suddenly i was
ah
[ __ ]
okay so i need to go the other way
oh [ __ ] hell everything just
everything
oh that was close okay
still fall
i wish i could just have walked on the
edge it would have been so much easier
hello
evil tire
yeah this thing it looks so ominous it
looks like the devil but it wasn't it's
just
hello
yes
i've got that one big one where where
of course
[ __ ] of
course do i go [ __ ]
flair time
nice to see you too okay
what do you mean as if he knew him or
something
oh sweet
give me a call
[Music]
feel my wrath
[ __ ] you
yeah
i don't know what that noise was but i'm
not even gonna look
i'm too busy causing havoc
being the nightmare
i am the nightmare
you think you're the nightmare [ __ ] you
it's so much better when you're in a car
oh don't fall into it
go around it
kill it kill it
kill it
ah
[ __ ] what is down here i don't want it
what is it
hello
oh it's another car oh my god we're
gonna have
a car off it's gonna be a tower off this
that car's got little flames on it
oh my god it's a monster truck we can't
compete we can't compete i bought a boat
we can't compete with the monster truck
oh my god it's here
[Music]
yes yes get out go backwards go
backwards other side ah [ __ ] off okay
fine
oh no
oh no
i [ __ ] it
okay boys
you're against me now
you might have a chance
come on we load you little wanker sorry
i should i should really try not to
swear i just wear so much
i'm playing this game
so bad okay
get this bad boy
where are they oh [ __ ]
eat that up
oh my god you're gonna take so much
oh it's okay it's getting smaller
slowly but surely i'll [ __ ] you oh god
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
oh wait
[Music]
dude
it would be nice if i could get back in
the car though [ __ ] it
bonjour sam jones
it'd be nice if we could buy some more
flares to be honest
i think i've been a bit reckless now
that i don't have my car
[ __ ] this i already can't be asked why
is that burnt here
ah oh my god it was a piece of corn
yeah i mean they are likely to be fat
true let's go in here
oh big lights
anything for me to pick up any goodies
come on there's got to be some goodies
in here
i mean there's a car so you know
that's always good
i don't like this
hello
hello
[ __ ] yeah
hello
hello
okay
maybe on the way back
hello
why is it
it's laid out like someone is gonna be
there but no one is
okay
there's really nothing else here it's
just a car i mean i am happy to find the
car but ah
fine fine fine fine
i mean we got one flare
i guess
boom boom
on the road again
i'm back on the boat again
[Music]
wait is that an ammo box no it's 50 mile
on our side street
what's happening
oh god drive
i stopped i should have just gone faster
oh my god
oh god oh my god
i'm scared
i don't know what to do let's crash
okay
um we just keep going
uh more [ __ ] is happening but we're just
gonna keep on going
going going keep going going going
okay
get out of the car there's no way for us
to go now
oh [ __ ] yeah nearly missed that it's
gonna drive right past it dwight drive
uh how many ammos we got for this dude
yes
that is a disgusting noise is that a
flare
no it's just the top of the truck i
thought it was a flare no sometimes okay
can you walk up this little log
[Music]
don't really know why we did this
oh [ __ ] there's all people just go
go into the light go into the light go
into the light they won't follow you
there
i swear i saw them walking down there
they probably are there
anyway
oh no this game is making me feel
paranoid like i don't know what to
believe anymore
oh [ __ ]
your blood bits oh there's flowers right
here
how goes the nightmare
pretty good we're about to finish it
this is the last episode
okay red barrel keep that in mind
if i could probably oh [ __ ] i knew it
okay well if we if we get this way we
can blow the red barrels
yes [ __ ]
ah jesus christ
jesus christ
oh my god oh my god
okay
this is getting insane
[ __ ]
okay reload your weapon please
good boy good boy good boy
who's the good way he yes
your weapons
oh that was a good judge oh that was a
bad dog
can't no
refuse to die
can i not pick up that other thing
or is that a used one that might be a
used one
so i use one oh sweet
[Music]
oh god i gotta get away from
no one got nobody got hurt by that that
was a waste
that was a waste of a red bar i'm sorry
bower
i could have used you for better things
time to read
the bottom of calder lake was a
graveyard of things the lake had claimed
in one way or another over the decades
the dark presence brought them up in its
wake scattering the rotten water logged
hull of an old boat here the remains of
a long-ago crashed airplane there trees
shattered under the impacts the earth
groaned it didn't even notice
hmm
the farmer called it was graveyard
things that laker claimed
fair enough and the dark president
brought them up that's why weird things
are here okay thanks for explaining that
to me game because i was i was wondering
oh another car
don't mind if i did
have a good boy wick yes
he's a good boy when he's not
running out of stamina that is bad
[Music]
[Music]
coming through trying not to crash
coming through
[Music]
oh yes
i see i see
i wish you could like leave the
leave the cards running with their
lights on because then you could
position them to get some help
thanks for the checkpoint
where is it pointing to
back here oh yes
it's so weird that whenever we find
these we hear our
wives
i don't like that that was so mean
it was before it even picked up the
stuff
oh that was so mean
oh that was awful
i hated that
sorry about your ears
oh that was
scary i didn't like it
more things down here
i feel like there's loads of secrets
around here but i don't think so
i'm just running around in circles okay
it's okay alan get back to the lights
you like it in here
yummy
okay
can we go in here
oh yeah so that's another way to get to
that
special place
[ __ ] i thought you were inside
you are inside i knew it
there's a red bell here if i need it
now i know
what does it say all visitors must see
the yard manager you must sign a
liability waiver before entering the
yard if you're looking for a specific
part ask for it first for you palette
you must bring your own tools wear
protective clothing warning jug piles
may shift hazardous area
okay
okay
there's another one there too
uh do we want to switch
how much ammo nine for that one
and i think six for this one isn't it
eight
i do quite like the pump action though
ask for it we'll just keep swapping
please hello
why there's so many red barrels in here
it's making me uncomfortable maybe it's
just a thematic thing
because it makes sense i guess
oh boo yes
flashbangs are
very handy
and a second
okay
okay
what will this do turn off the light
oh it opens the door
[ __ ]
i hate this
whoa no i didn't want to use that gun
jesus it had it also equipped no i
wasted it
i'm not sticking around to see what that
is
let's go
bye
[Music]
this is like a driving level
oh no
oh
there's nothing around here
i think i see something on the floor
zayn cut its heart out but it didn't die
the thing that wore barbara's face kept
pruning sweet nothings sugar laced with
poison
he put on the suit untied the monster
from the chair the thing in his arms
thrashed weakly but he held fast he
stepped outside off the pier and into
the dark water a sinking pinprick of
light descending toward a bottom that
never came
he stepped out outside of the pier and
he said i would so he was holding
her heart like his
i guess his lover's heart but it wasn't
because it was taken over by the dark
presence and it was thrashing around
[Music]
exactly julio our boy is going to wake
up
i'm guessing
oh really yeah
uh-oh
hello bro
there's a snag
what did that even do where's the button
down there
hello i'm just gonna stay up here until
they until they show themselves
show yourself
show your face
okay
do it
drive
oh [ __ ] off
no
no
oh my god
how did you get out there
i didn't tell you to get out of the car
i think the car [ __ ]
oh my god i need to hide
hide
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
right don't use that flare gun um
reload
good boy
where did we go now
oh
why can't you jump on that thing what is
wrong with you why can't you do basic
human things
but you can use
you can use light switches like that
okay so oh it's down here right okay
words
they are hard
can we go in this car
no definitely not
reload reload someone's coming reload
okay let's go
i mean faster would be nice but i'll let
you do your thing
[Music]
let him catch his breath
so i was like i don't think there is a
car anymore
there was a car but yeah it definitely
wasn't drivable anymore
but that's fine because we have a new
one
the game just keeps gifting us cars
any pickups any flush
see things
any
sources of bright light
or ammunition i mean ammunition is
always nice
okay fine
let's get in the car and go
let's shut up and drive
he just fits on the radio
it's like sugar babes or whoever sings
that
showed up and dread
who was that
no idea
[Music]
baby
that was good
good drift
thank you very much
when i told barry my plan back in the
well-lit room i'd acted as if i knew
what i was doing
i didn't i was operating on the shifting
logic of a dream i had to fight my way
to the lake through the horrors of the
night i had to flick an old battered
light switch imbued with childhood magic
i had to write a happy ending to a
horror story i had to save my wife from
the dark prison she was being held in
yep
it's okay we all believe in you
i think do we
i do
there's another arrow i guess it points
me up into the house
what does it say follow yes
follow
okie dokie then
um
that's weird i don't recall have you
ever been having to do this input before
like quick tap to push
have i
this is very strange that it's like a
a new action in the last episode
oh no
whenever you see these lights you know
something's gonna go down
there's a big
okay okay okay okay should we switch
switcheroo
yes please
[Music]
i will never give her to you
it's so [ __ ] loud
everybody hide
oh this is my head
staying here they can all come to me
because i've got these two lands and i
feel i feel great
i feel great about my situation i don't
want to change it
fine i'm gonna have to just go
what's in this house
about
nice
yeah what's in this house
banana
don't need it
yet
what's in this house
absolutely nothing
coffee
oh i don't want
i don't want these
oh
why has nothing happened yet
i don't like the suspense of just going
into the houses
oh that is a massive ass lamp
oh
okay
they kill you with my lamp
i kill you
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
can i am
can i get this over here
no i can't
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
we're all fine
we are not [ __ ] fine look at these
they're massive
i'm just a little boy
i should already change my gun i'm too
scared i don't know what to do
come on behind me
oh thank god
change your gun i mean reload
stay in this light
you'll feel good
i feel the boys
they do
uh where are those other guns
i think there are a couple houses back
maybe in this one
okay let's change for the hunting rifle
now
uh another shotgun
because we need
to be able to come on hold it yeah i'm
holding it okay
i need to be able to shoot in quick
succession
uh
okay
that's not too bad oh wait did that have
some ammo in there some of them has i
had ammo in there
that i thought i didn't need but i do
need now
here we go
oh
oh
i'm barrel walking
i swear i just heard a door open but
there's no
i thought it was triggered whenever i
walked through here it would be a door
opening sound but now
this is random
spooky wow
come on
a little hop
the dark place i found myself in was
unlike anything i could ever have
imagined
it wasn't solid it flowed it was
conceptual and subjective
for someone else an artist in another
field it would have been very different
i could sense the story of the
manuscript all around me the words and
ideas floating in the air always to
become real
it's such a cool and different idea this
i'm really interested
interested to see
where they take it in the next game as
well
and when they were like oh yeah it's
gonna be more survival horror because
the last game was a bit more action
i kind of see what they mean but also i
think this game is really scary
there's definitely been moments where
i've been terrified i mean even this
play through there's been moments where
i've been terrified but
but yeah i guess i'm gonna have those
moments
but more often throughout the game
it's definitely a really great premise
for a survival horror so i think they'll
do great
i believe in them
where has he gone
oh
once you step into the light that just
disappeared that's good
i could see near a peak in the distance
that's where cauldron lake was
okay
yeah mark
hopefully less jump scares more
psychological they can definitely do
that
just the premise of this works so well
you're a writer so you're not
necessarily great at combat or whatever
and a world that you don't know what to
trust like you don't know what to trust
what's real and
and what's imagination
i guess we jumped down from up there
oh cool
fun
hey birdies this is going to be a bride
pot isn't it oh
hey montas you made it welcome
there's going to be another one
there's going to be loads
i'm not ready for this
where do we stop
okay
oh okay
i thought there's going to be way more
birdies
oh wait go bam
what's up what's up why would i want to
go out there
do i want to go
[ __ ] why was that so [ __ ] loud okay
well i'm going in here first
and then i'll go back
oh i think i got them i think i got them
while i was climbing the ladder so i
didn't even me to get them but i did
i am smart
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
get down
i'm wondering if i missed something if i
went down here
yes
oh is this something different
yeah okay i'll go down here
oh
come on get in yet
how are you doing mantas
it's going to be the last stream of 2021
awesome i'm so glad we went down again
i just saw shinies and i was like oh yes
should we switch again 16
and how many do we have here
nine oh yeah we're definitely switching
switch
ah
okay and then back up
are you going to play the smaller sequel
american nightmare
probably not if i'm honest um i think
there's probably
games i want to play
uh
instead of that because i haven't heard
anything about that which probably means
that it wasn't a very good game but if
anyone knows i mean let me know but i
i haven't really heard anything about it
so i'll put this way into the new one
so they could sneak up on me
they did sneak up on me
yeah my [ __ ]
foreign
oh this is a big one this is a big one
oh my god i think his friend just killed
him i think the thing that it fruits it
looked like that way
i hope it was that because that's so
hilarious
but it could have just been me
one of my rapid firing but it looked
like he threw something and it it killed
him in the bag
let me know what you think in the
comments
i think it's mate kills him ha ha
okay let's go in
here not step on the icky black stuff
oh
apparently the game is only two and
three two to three hours the american
nightmare one fair enough
it's very short i did not expect that
thank you very much
hello
they're not even on anything they're
just
hovering in thin air
i have been so good with my ammo i
probably need to use
my better guns and stuff
they've just been conserving it way too
much
but i never know when i'm gonna need it
the most
and i've been
in that position with no ammo and no
batteries way too much in alan wake and
i hate it
damn
damn d damn damn damn damn
where'd he go where'd he go where'd he
go where'd he go where'd he go
i hate this one this is speedy
you gotta go fast
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's so fast
where we did
come on guys
oh big boy
hello
to your
generator i'm going to just run up to it
and just do it
one oh [ __ ]
there's ammo near here two
three yeah
thank you
what should we start using our good gun
yeah
let's do it
no
no i don't want that one
yeah this one
wow
how [ __ ] is he i can't focus he gotta
get back gotta get back gotta get back
to the light
baby
where is he
he's over there right okay now i can see
it
oh these [ __ ] bushes
oh my gosh he is so freaking annoying i
want this guy dead
[ __ ] you oh god
oh god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
okay
back
how did they not [ __ ] kill it
okay
hey
i didn't need to do that right either
i don't care i just want this
i just want the coffee
i just want the coffee i just want the
oh [ __ ] hell jesus christ
oh god i hate them they're so fast i
already hate them
no [ __ ]
okay
where is it
all right quickly reload only a little
gun
bullet
good boy okay
now don't forget that coffee
yummy flashbang
i love both
oh
don't follow me [ __ ] that's what you
get
you imagine me being like a mafia boss
uh which way am i going i'm like i think
i'm going the wrong way but this is
where it tells me to go
up the hill right
stop what the hell where did you even
come from
what the [ __ ]
what is happening
i don't even know
once
oh my gosh
okay okay
leave me two with you i can
chill out now
i do have neighbors um but they're not
directly next to my walls no so fingers
crossed
okay
oh [ __ ] off peanut no
okay okay okay okay okay
i'll kill him i'll kill him
but he's gonna get over here
can you even come up here
oh yeah
yes
it's that question
okay
let's reload all my guns
this one is that one reloaded yes okay
good good
all the neighbors know she just wants
coffee now yeah and i probably just
wonder like every thursday i just have
someone called alan over and i just yell
it
well alan
this is your time to take back nope
you're fine
oh god did you hear that it's a big
screen
[Music]
it's probably me for the future i'm from
the past
what
so much is happening i literally can't
keep up with it
oh yeah of course because it's all just
falling from the bottom of the lake
oh that's a log can we go into the ship
can we go in the ship
of course he's got to catch his breath
hey solid no this is actually the last
episode of alan wake
episode six
but it's oh but it is my first time
playing through the game if that's what
you mean yes
yeah i never played it when i was
younger
is that anything oh there is no basement
okay
um okay
the darkness
controls the taken we know you've told
us so many times
okay let's go over there
there's gonna be a big fight here isn't
there
okay
let me just drop down
oh was i supposed to drop down from up
there
oh
he looked like he'd hurt himself
alan's very gentle and
you know
gentle
oh we can drop down this good
he's fragile that's what i mean
ooh cool
let's go into this house why are there
so many random ambient sounds of doors
being opened and closed when there are
no doors around it's so weird
see that everywhere
surely you can hear it too i can't be
the only one who's hearing these
door opening and closing sounds
oh i can go up here
okay yeah let's do this
one
[ __ ] off
ah
oh thank god okay okay that's that one
gentleman
cool cool cool cool cool
jesus where did you come from man
okay
oh
i was so sure i was gonna get out of
that one
[ __ ] sick
i'm glad you like it when it suddenly
gets loud autumn
because that happens a lot on this
channel
uh okay yeah so we can't use that until
i've turned on that fair enough
far enough
there was nothing in here was there in
there oh wait no there are these
let me just i'm getting hot and
flustered
just once like
[Music]
i wish it saved here
why wouldn't it save here for me game
okay
let's do better
[Music]
right
oh yeah [ __ ]
she walked through the electricity
that was good i like that
are we still fighting
because i'm acting like we're not
i'm acting like it's over so game can
you comply
[ __ ]
no no no no
okay
is it over now i don't know
is there anything either
let's just [ __ ] go
please
please come down
please come
down oh yep
ah there we go
oh
strong door
rip headphone users oh i'm so excited um
we have uh some i guess i'd say we have
some uh
emotes coming around christmas and next
year when i go twitch only they'll be
for twitch users and
they'll be for discord and one of the
emotes is um
me with like headphones and screaming
and it's it's yeah represents rip
headphone users so this is so exciting
um but i'll share more more of that with
you soon it's going to be like a a
little christmas present after seeing it
gone i stood alone in the shifting dream
that was the dark place i had to find a
way to the cabin
i'd written myself a way through this
place in the manuscript i followed the
idea of a path
i'd written myself across the ocean that
blocked my way and with that there was a
bridge to the island beyond
the idea of the cabin flickered in the
underwater darkness i willed the cabin
to be real and it was
crazy
it's kind of like the neverending story
it's all about imagination
power of your imagination
turn back now
[Music]
jesus christ
this woman ain't messing around
[ __ ] out
she is not messing around
foreign
[Music]
of course
he's like stuck up in the boat somehow
hello
oh he's gone he just despawned okay well
that's fine by me i'm not gonna complain
can i go
let's reload
you as you're told
now
oh scheisse okay hold up
wait a little bit for my my health to go
back up very slowly
alice never left you she did
storm ladies and gentlemen
and
anybody else here
[Applause]
we should be okay
just stay by the edges
what are we gonna do now
come on
come on
get out of the way
i don't trust it oh [ __ ] oh my god get
out of its way
okay good boy
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] up
okay okay stay here for a sec
regain your health
just stand
you like to stand
there's so much going on
stand here until we get a bit more help
[Applause]
okay
i think we're good i think we're good
oh my god oh my god oh my god
what am i doing
[Applause]
surely that's gonna help
maybe not i don't know is it helping
yeah it must be because they're just
giving me some more hair
i had to get light into its heart to
hurt it oh i know mate
yes
oh my god
[Applause]
oh it takes so long to actually fire the
flag and it's very annoying
[Applause]
okay should we just let's just go
forward
[Applause]
there's a lot of things in the way still
[Applause]
[ __ ] no
it just came i thought i was free
uh okay
[Applause]
oh my god i [ __ ] jump
that was my bad
okay
yeah okay
[Applause]
try and get all this stuff out of the
way
[Applause]
i think this box is just infinite ammo
for the flag
right by me
oh
i had to get light into its heart to
hurt it oh i know but i also want to get
the stuff out of the way so i don't jump
in to do it again
okay pick up pick up some more ammo
at least
i think 12 is max yeah
and then try and find a good time to go
now
where the [ __ ] am i
for some reason i thought it looked like
he was holding your little water pistols
like a little toy again
you did it
okay and we go
help
shh baby you were having a bad dream
it was just another nightmare
no
everything's fine you're home
it wasn't a dream everything's fine
turn the lights on
turn the lights
[Music]
shh
on
the power's out there's no light
come back to bed and i'll make you
forget all about your fear in the dark
why'd you fear it it's your fear yeah
why aren't you afraid you're not alice
turn the lights on now oh
the darkness is consuming hair form
you're not making any sense
come back to bed
no
yes
stand my ground no
i'm having a shower alan you're scaring
me now come back to bed have you taken
your pills do you want me to call dr
hartman
why you acting all sexy in the front
room you read your manuscript it's
brilliant departure is your best work
yet you're a genius i'm so proud of you
come back to bed we'll talk more about
it in the morning
can i just leave out the front door no
sorry i don't i don't know why my pc
does it sometimes
just
minimizes the game
oh i'm finding the clicker come back to
bedtime connects
[Music]
oh i didn't know i still had a
flashlight
[Music]
[Music]
you must find your way to the cabin
it stands in your way if all that you
pass
it has no heart
it's filled with darkness
it must fill its heart with light
i thought i did oh was the tornado not
its heart
i guess
not
why is he looking
[Music]
the himself version of him
[Music]
i hope mr scratch won't hurt our friends
oh this is weird
they're all
words instead of actual things because
this whole
place and story is from
the book they're made out of words
that's all they ever were oh cool
and then they turn into the actual
things once we
oh that's really cool
hello
i followed the idea of a path
that's cool
this is really cool i love this
[Applause]
yeah i don't care about birds
i'm leaving you
what i'm leaving
i'm in love with someone else
else what's she saying no what do you
say you can't you don't
who are you what have you done with my
alice some people don't want to be mises
though
i didn't light back on what are you
doing alex stop put the light back on
it wasn't true
nothing like that had ever happened
you're not my barbara tom let me go
i promise to be good
please
naughty boy
i will help you write your masterpiece i
will love you forever and tiny
put that knife away thomas put it down
my heart is filled with darkness i'll
cut it out
i'll take you back to the gym
oh yeah it's just like we read
he took our heart out darkness
get away from me but it was still moving
where am i let me go
now you will never get her back
i am much older than you
older than your first work of art
i will find a new face to wear
someone else can dream me free
she was like what a hug
acceptance
no
no
just plunging the clicker into your
heart
[Music]
the hug of death
[Music]
i could feel alice's presence close by
i understood what i had to do now
i knew how to write the ending to
departure
there's light and there's darkness
cause and effect there's guilt and
there's atonement
but the scales always need to balance
everything has a price that's where
saying had gone wrong
there's a long journey through the night
back into the light
alice
alice
oh so he's literally just rewriting
everything
oh no
[Music]
i think
from that moment when she was taken
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
she made it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
she's gotta be cold
someone get her a towel
[Music]
therefore it's pretty nice be a
nice beautiful music yeah nice beautiful
music in this game because
[Music]
is that
that can't be the end
is that the end
i feel like i still don't know a lot of
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
literally the beginning
[Music]
oh no they're having the parade
[Music]
where's barry
[Music]
okay
uh-oh
who the hell is that behind her that's
pretty creepy
it's not a lake
it's an ocean
alan
wake up
what
i still have so many questions
there was no
resolutions what
yeah exactly deaf what
i'm so confused everyone's just like
i still don't know a lot of stuff that's
how we all feel yes 11 years later oh no
no
i can't i can't monetize any of these
videos by the way because of the music
but the music is very good in these
games oh wow i'm like i'm
very happy to play this very much
enjoyed the game love the premise really
excited to see what they do for alan
wake too however
i am just
disappointed
that like
i don't know just i wanted to know more
i want to visit i wanted resolutions
with the wife i wanted resolutions with
barry i want resolutions with um
alan wake as a writer like where is his
career is it okay i want resolutions
with the darkness in the lake it can
still exist that's fine by me but i want
some kind of resolution i don't need
full answers to exactly what's going on
because i feel like it's very like hp
lovecraftian which you don't you don't
really explain that
um so that's fine by me
but i at least like want these
resolutions for these characters and not
not only resolutions i want explanations
of like what was going on with alan wake
and his wife because there was a lot of
times through playing that where you got
the sense that his wife actually didn't
want to be with him and they were having
like a lot of problems
um
so then that led me to think maybe some
of this is just in his head and you know
their relationship isn't as great as he
thinks it is and all those freaking
times where you can just hear
i thought it was his wife like breathing
in his ears
like these weird ambient noises
why was he hearing those because i was
just like is he in a coma
i don't know oh
so
yeah so strange i'm definitely gonna
have to watch loads of uh
loads of like alan wake videos now to
see what the different conspiracies are
for what it all means but
i mean i can definitely see why people
still talk about it to this day i
really really enjoyed this game so thank
you to everybody who
suggested that i play it
very very happy that i played it i'm
gonna look in the at the comments now
and see what you think
it's still not satisfying but it helps
with you a few things is that the
the second i recommend playing the two
dlc episodes and the sequel
oh i didn't know those two dlc episodes
okay
thank you for that sam that might be a
good good shout out you need to wait for
alawite to yeah i do hope with alan wake
too they actually do carry on with this
story it would be good it would be good
to get some more clarification some
conclusions
mainly honestly i mean
i love the whole
uh dark presence in the lake kind of
from like an otherwise or an ancient an
ancient power i really think that's cool
i don't think it needs too much more
explanation though i think keeping it a
mystery is fine by me
but i want to know about his
relationship
i just want that i want to know what's
happening there it doesn't seem like
it's as it's nice as
as uh alan wake really thinks it is uh i
do think they are having some serious
problems
um
well time to read theories online all
night yeah exactly sydney so exactly
you should buy the dlc and continue
i will think about it i will think about
it def
probably but we'll we'll see i'm coming
back next year so we'll see what i come
back with
uh maybe we'll take some time out in
between and maybe come back to it
thank you for the journey jag ah thanks
infinite you are very very welcome and
thanks again for your super chat i
really really appreciate that
what will we be playing next i don't
know so this is the thing this is the
last stream of 2021
and then i won't be back until until
next year so if you want to follow me
and find out what i'm doing when i'll be
streaming next what i'll be streaming
next wow love because i am taking a
little bit of a break i don't know when
i'm coming back scary i'm gonna come
back
but i don't know when exactly i'll be
coming back so make sure that you're
following me on twitter instagram uh on
the discord and that is like i say where
some of the emotes will be coming for
christmas so that'll be very exciting uh
i'll just put a little link to the
discord in here
generate link
join
uh and yeah so you can
join the discord you can follow me on
twitter
you can follow me on instagram
basically i won't be going from
everything um but yeah i will be taking
a break from all of this because i need
to travel see my family won't be around
the computer all that jazz um but i hope
you have a really nice holiday i hope
you get to spend it with some people
that you love or at least get to relax
and do things that you enjoy
all that good stuff
uh
hello again clay
all right well
thank you again for joining me i'm gonna
say goodbye to who i can see in the
stream
uh it's so weird that this is the last
stream of 2021 but it's okay we'll be
back we'll be back
and it'll be fun
so goodbye sidnata goodbye sam jones
goodbye cars goodbye
thomas
sunlight now i'm so sorry just butchered
your surname but thomas
goodbye a196 goodbye def157
goodbye infinite
goodbye officer naruto
goodbye
uh do you look at the camera away from
the camera a lot i look everywhere i
have like something here and something
there so i'm looking at everything
um
you should have the dlc on pc and
american nightmare
really
okay i'll take a look sam i'll take a
look and see if i've got that uh
i think that might be everyone goodbye
clay are we saying goodbye clay
um
goodbye marked ruid
ah thomas was like no gonna cry
don't cry i'm not gone i'm not gone
i'm not gone i'm coming back hey sean
but i'm sorry we're leaving now but
thanks anyway for coming oh and everyone
this is your last call
this should be my uh last restream so
that's like the last time i stream on
both youtube and twitch so make sure
that you are following me on twitch
because i'm going to be doing most of my
streams on twitch only next year
so
yeah please do make sure that you make a
twitch account and you follow me on
there but i'll let you know on like
discord and twitter and everything else
anyways so don't worry about that
uh you did pretty well with my name
congrats okay okay thank you thank you
uh cat louise is back but i'm sorry we
have to go
so at least i can say goodbye to you so
goodbye cat louise thank you so much for
everyone coming have a wonderful
wonderful time off i really hope you get
to
to chill out and have have some nice
time
um and goodbye caz as well
uh i'll see you in the new year i'll
chat to you on discord and stuff okay
i'm gonna go now i'm just like rambling
and stuff okay
bye oh thanks for all the laughs and
good moments happy holidays oh thank you
too cars